foreign
I want to work with people who are kind
people who genuinely are optimistic
people
I I'm not really excited working with
Skeptics who just yeah see what could go
wrong all the time look I'm a cockeyed
Optimist I'm you know I'm so damn
optimist
that I basically see the wine glasses
half full even before I pull the cork on
the bottle but it's important for me to
surround myself with people who at least
ask me some tough questions so I want
kind optimists I definitely want Curious
people who look at each I don't I don't
want know-it-alls I want learn it all's
I don't want someone who's already a
finished product it's not fun especially
if you're trying to make your business
better every day
I definitely want people who have an
excellent work ethic I don't mean you
know to the point of being sick because
we can all push it too far but
it's not fun to be on a team where
everybody's really bringing their best
and and there's a couple people just
putting in a c-level effort that doesn't
work and I definitely want empathetic
people people who understand the Wake
they leave in their path who care about
how they make other people feel just as
much as they care how other people feel
so yeah and and definitely I want
self-aware people and I want people with
Integrity so 100 of those the one thing
I would add that
has really really come to light for me
is I I want people
who
who just love to win
because because that's not really
captured in any of the six that I
mentioned earlier
wanting to be a champion you look at the
best athletes in sports
sure they have god-given physical
ability
but they also had to train like crazy
you know you don't get to be the
Kentucky Derby winner without you got
your Bloodlines but you also had to
train like crazy you don't get to be
Serena Williams
without the Bloodlines but you don't
also get to be Serena Williams without
working incredibly hard or Michael
Jordan whoever it is you want to talk
about so I look for that
I'm really interested to know the
motivation behind what makes someone
competitive and I basically have four
buckets first of all there's a
competitive people people who are
they're great people
they just don't wake up every day saying
you know I gotta win I'm dying to win
Tim Ferriss did not get to be Tim
Ferriss without Desiring to be the best
I know that and that doesn't necessarily
come across but you're not a competitive
I can tell you that then the other three
buckets I look for and this helps me
with someone's self-awareness as well
is to understand
assuming that you are motivated to be a
champion at what you do
what's the what is your primary
motivation for wanting to compete to win
and I find there's basically three
buckets sometimes people have a little
bit of each but there's the
you know that picture of Muhammad Ali's
standing triumphantly over Sonny Liston
whose back is on the Middle with his
fist up in the air so I can pretty much
tell you that Muhammad Ali
was primarily motivated by a love for
beating someone else
that felt really good to him
and that's not it's not a bad thing or a
good thing just is what it is then you
got imagine this photograph of John
Mcenroe with his headband on in his long
curly hair
yelling at the Umpire you've got to be
kidding me
that man hated to lose
it wasn't so much I'm motivated by
who I'm gonna beat it's like like I will
not be seen losing
and then the third image I would have
would be
a great Olympian let's say Usain Bolt
and his leg is outstretched with the
veins popping
right trying to get that extra inch or
that extra half second off of his time
or whatever
and that guy is he's out there his
primary motivation he wants to exceed
his own personal best he's competing
with himself so by knowing
these questions this is something that I
would absolutely want to add today
because because I know that I want to be
the best
and I can't do it by myself so I got to
be I gotta stock my team with people who
look at every day as an opportunity not
for Perfection because I think
Perfection is stupid it's impossible
it's a recipe for unhappiness but I do
look for people
who look at every day as an opportunity
to honor whatever they did yesterday and
figure out how to do it a little bit
better today that's that's the Journey
of Excellence